[Music]
so when we look at UAV platforms or
drones as we call them commonly there
are multiple different types of
platforms there is rotary devices a
multi rotor and then there's fixed-wing
UAV platforms fixed-wing cover the
larger use cases where you're talking
about flying them anywhere from two
thousand 16,000 going up to 35,000 which
is the regular airspace under which
aircrafts operate as well and fixed-wing
UAVs are categorized by their say size
and weight starting from Group one which
is the smallest going up to group five
which are the larger ones which carry
way larger payloads and might also be
used for offensive purposes what might
carry missiles and other things so these
grouping actually we for example Krause
aerospace it's a private company not a
defense so we only play within that
group one two group four platforms where
they're primarily focused or group three
platforms they've primarily focused on
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance or payload that provide
things like communication signal
intelligence you are talking about radio
relay or payloads that do lidar or
electro optical or infrared camera so
any kind of visual payloads that allow
and facilitate for decision-makers to
make rapid decisions on the ground so
this conversation is very timely
everybody is hearing about space forests
and what the government is doing there
or their articles all over DARPA talking
about it and DARPA is investing in it
Lockheed Martin Raytheon others are kind
of coming in together to help us so
essentially if you take a look at it we
are fairly dependent on the satellites
that are out there to launch a satellite
to repair a satellite to do maintenance
around a satellite there's an extremely
expensive proposition and those are also
very easy to take out right so if there
is a certain missile that attacks and
there are four or five countries in the
world that actually have anti satellite
that can take out a satellite but that's
not the only way of crippling a
satellite you could do jamming you could
do multiple things where the receivers
are the signals other components that
are associated with satellites you mess
with any of that it kind of takes out a
satellite right so for example I think
it was back in January of 2016 that we
were we have 13 or 14 GPS satellites out
there and we were taking down one of
them and there was a really mining 100
millisecond or 300 millisecond
difference in sync in terms of because
there was some components that were
introduced that caused lapse in the time
and because from a GPS or when you use
GPS to guide you time is extremely
important and syncing up of that where
you were before and where you are now
and that's how GPS can guide you and so
if there is a there is a break in that
sync you suddenly will go off and we
experienced that in January of 2016 for
very small period but that shows you
even the smallest things can literally
bring down an entire country to their
knees when some of these critical
satellites are taken out but when you
think of persistent platforms or long
endurance or non-stop platforms
redundancy is a key component that
actually has to be covered across
multiple of these components redundancy
in communication redundancy in energy
sources that's where the multiple energy
sources comes in right so we utilize a
ram air turbine which essentially would
drop down and can utilize the wind
energy to give that push that the
aircraft might need to carry it through
the night so that when the solar panels
take over they're able to charge we
would use similar batteries like
lithium-ion which goes into a Tesla or a
lithium polymer battery then combine
that what we have done is we've written
code that allows us to detect thermals
or uplift similar to what a bird would
do great birds don't get tired they soar
they keep soaring and they identify
thermals and that's how they do it we've
captured that from an AI perspective you
know and thought the machine or the
autopilot
detect these thermals algorithmically
using a linear quadratic equation Kalman
filter what that means is even the
slightest movement that happens on the
wings it's detected and then the center
of that thermal is detected so that the
aircraft can stay up pretty much with no
amperage eases from the lithium-ion
battery or the little polymer battery
that is on board so now what you've done
is you're utilizing natural energy
sources for nonstop performance now if
we take it a step further and you hear a
lot about this which is swarm
intelligence so the likes of MIT and
others and we're doing work within the
space all of this is nature how can you
utilize what's happening in nature and
mimic that with technology so when we
spoke about thermo lling or using uplift
to keep the aircraft flying without
actually using external energy we've
learned from the bullets now swarm
intelligence is how actual insects and
other is kind of in a group in a swarm
communicate and function together if we
are able to bring that technology in in
different ways so swarming can happen in
multiple ways when you're talking about
manned or unmanned platforms so you have
a swarm can be you're coordinating with
your land platform with your air
platform with your space platform and
all of them are functioning based in a
specific mission that's been defined for
them or what I was talking about earlier
identifying thermals or when we talk
about high altitude pseudo satellite
there are no thermals there but what we
have there is what is called
stratospheric wind so we can use that
win the the aircraft similar to when you
stand against wind coming your way and
you balance it by moving forward we can
actually linger up there at 65 to 70,000
feet using that stratospheric wind and
keeping our aircraft up so when you're
doing that you can then also communicate
between multiple different platforms
that you might launch at 65 where they
would actually essentially be sitting at
65 to 70
thousand feet and they're all
coordinating amongst themselves first to
identify these natural energy sources
second to communicate amongst themselves
and create a mesh network so now you're
suddenly creating an alternative which
is a very viable alternative for
satellites that don't have to be
actually brought down they can be kept
up for as long as you want when you want
to swap out a payload suddenly there's
new technology in terms of sensors in
terms of how you can do radio relay how
you can do wireless services you bring
those down and swap out the payload it's
fraction of the cost and it's doable you
want to bring it down for maintenance
bring it down otherwise keep it up right
and then you're utilizing multiple
sources like nuclear and others to keep
it up for non-stop and you create a mesh
network that's one of the other things
that space forces vision is as well to
create some sort of a mesh network that
counters what the enemies can do to our
satellites because if you have one
single target it is easy to take it down
but if you have multiple even one is
taken down the others will take over so
you suddenly safeguarding how you're
providing communication wireless
services if our mesh network would have
been up we would have been able to bring
up Puerto Rico from Lou you know not
having connectivity from months or a
whole year to dates we would have read
out at an entire wireless mesh network
to support getting them up and running
on communication that's just one example
[Music]